c'est officiel nepad le bois soleil et
la résidence seniors les jardins du bois
soleil ont été inaugurés jeudi 21
octobre à bois d'arcy le directeur de
l'établissement
très émue durant cette cérémonie où
enfin le travail de plusieurs années
accomplies le projet a pris plus de
trois ans pour être constitué et c'est
avec la fusion des deux établissements
et la création du groupe tenaris qui a
permis effectivement de faire venir cet
établissement à la vie et donc voilà
c'est pour ça que l'émotion et c'est
beaucoup de travail cet établissement de
haut standing compte une maison de
retraite médicalisée qui peut accueillir
jusqu'à 80 lits et une résidence pour
seniors composée de 30 appartements de
deux pièces des logements adaptés et
sécurisés pour les résidents ont trouvé
comment
s'aimer deux grands parents qui sont là
mes grands parents paternels et on a
choisi cet établissement là parce que
moi j'habite à côté du coup en passant
devant j'ai vu que c'était trop neuf et
que ça avait l'air bien du coup sont
venus visiter savoir plus de nombreuses
animations sur le thème du cinéma était
organisée pour l'occasion comme de la
danse bollywood dans ces deux structures
une salle de sport un salon de coiffure
et d'esthétique et une salle de jeux
sont mises à disposition cet
établissement était un véritable besoin
pour la commune qui compte plus de 2000
seniors je revois des gens que je voyais
dans l'art dans la rue ou chez eux il ya
quelques années et que je retrouve
aujourd'hui maintenant dans cet ehpad
c'est à dire que c'est devenu un lieu
central de la circonscription les
artisiens souhaité reste à voir si c'est
une particularité de 2,8 c'est assez
incroyable et c'est une chance qu'on a
avoué darcis près de 500 personnes ont
plus de 80 ans
[Applaudissements]